il a préparé j'ai vu ça sur un stade il
a préparé le petit déjeuner pour sa
femme avec des un canard laqué sa peau
là pour la femme de feu d'avoir une meuf
[Musique]
tu voulais que ça pour maxime c'est pas
sa foi mais m une aventure avec un ou
une députée dans un avion non ça c'est
dit
oui je pense aussi que benjamin c'est
que bassam à six mois j'avais une
aventure et alors vous mais moi de vous
dire ça mais je vous aime beaucoup me
line quoi mais question est ce que j'ai
une question à vous poser qu'on se pose
un petit peu parce que c'est pas un peu
mytho parce que non mais on m'accepte
c'est la vérité donc quand à utah a
couché avec passion qu'il s'agit dans un
anneau non non non
castanet sinon ce rac certaines fois on
sait on commence à vous cernez non c'est
bon parce que lui ça va a dit mcdowell
imago elle non mais attendez les tops
arrêter l'émission bastia problème n'est
pas tant mais je vais m'occuper de lui
pendant la pub j'ai encore lui met une
thalasso on va retrouver benjamin
castaldi voilà alors regardez il est
donc devant la tour tf1 revoyez voilà
c'est bien tf1 voilà fière d'être bleus
tf1 et il va faire juste un petit
passage
regardez attention benjamin castaldi
comme le streaker a bien sûr 2 samedi
soir
voilà
[Musique]
[Rires]
ça va ça va ça va il a qui l'attirent
blues ou encore à la hauteur alors là
qu'ils aillent dire bonjour c'est bon et
comment ça qui fait rentrer essaie de
rentrer c'est de rentrer les gens
survivent
l'élément qui m'a pas et je t'écris va
passer la soirée somme toute la soirée
va-t-on pélata meilleure édition et
kabadougou les garçons là où ça gueule
on va apprendre à nos téléspectateurs à
brimer la latence et sa jambe mais
attention majeure parce que d'accord
généralement temps là contrairement à ce
que dit ne jamais jamais trop près
d'accord mais qui fait qu'est ce t'as
tes morts moi je passe à dix ans après
que martin derrière les moyens moi je
tape et l'étape au genou droit mais non
mais je peux pas vous allez bien basile
par des bouffées
j'en ai bavé aucun respect à la banon
c'est très bousculée il fait le bois
alors qu'il est nul
c'est n'importe quoi pour que tu te bats
si l'on tape aux femmes j'adore le river
c'est vrai c'est miss france miss france
pour moi c'est delphine cdh est une
vraie filière pour moi n'y aura jamais
qu'une miss course ce sera toujours
delphine wespiser que vous le vouliez ou
non voilà préféré c'était va ya non ma
miss france préféré c'est delphine
wespiser et j'ai pas peur de ligne où il
va voilà qui quitte à choquer d'accord
fm chercheurs beaucoup de chance oui ça
va
qu'est-ce qui se passe ils vont mais du
bâtiment sont vraiment et moi c'est pas
bien c'est sympa mais vous vous avez
fait toute votre compteur c'est complexe
derrière soi arrêtez de mentir
vous êtes avec les gars vous êtes mon
animateurs préférés si ces modèles
acteurs préférés au chômage
ce soir
tous les coups sont permis aux dames et
messieurs sauf dans les galeries
de mettre le feu pour l'arrivée des
combattants
on commence par le challenger et
entraîne 7j 7 24 heures sur 24 depuis
six mois il a même perdu 15 kilos pour
le combat mais elle a repris 25 ce mois
ci un poste de match au cap
il est gonflé à bloc il ne pas tenir ce
que trois jours c'est du jamais vu
n'oubliez jamais qu'avec atteint ça
castagne mesdames et messieurs voici
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]